what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so about an hour ago at the time
that this video is being made CNBC came
out and they basically said that
according to sources quote-unquote
familiar with Project Disney and Fox are
closing in on a deal that should be
announced next week where Disney
basically gets all the titles back they
get the expert and they get the
Fantastic Four back dude I'm okay this
is like an update to the last video dude
I am so hyped I am so excited for that
because if it do man if it happens to
imagine that you've got the Avengers you
got the Fantastic Four it all in like
one great big huge thing do the
Fantastic Four give you the space
exploring team right like I just had a
bag that fell over the Fantastic Four
can be the space exploring team right
like instead of everything being
confined on earth the Fantastic Four
just explore space dude we would get
Galactus we would get the Silver Surfer
and now the stupid Galactus cloud that
Fox thought was a good idea like the big
purple guy Galactus with the purple
helmet dude I am dude that would be so
beast because I love Galactus like he's
so awesome did you guys see vanos
showing up on earth and stealing the
Infinity stones is a calamity
imagine if Galactus shows up now Thanos
with the Infinity Gauntlet is like way
more powerful than Galactus
but imagine like if go back to showed up
on earth dude oh hope would be lost to
the ultimate nullifier oh my god okay
guys so the ultimate nullifier was a
weapon that Galactus used for himself so
that it could basically just is like the
most powerful thing in existence it's
contextual based on who's wielding it
and like you have to focus and it's
really kind of like on your intelligence
so a person who was really smart and
really really focused could obliterate
the entirety of the universe whereas a
person who's kind of dumb and very
unfocused would basically like just
destroy themselves and that's that's
really that's kind of like the caveat
and the limit that goes in the hill
ultimate nullifier dude Abraxas is so
cool okay so there was this story there
was written back in the 1990s I think
know maybe he was like 2002 2003 I never
thought my head but it was it was one of
the craziest things ever alright so you
have the Fantastic Four right and like
Galactus is dying and Galactus warns
everyone if I die like if you guys allow
me to die you know because he's
basically starving running out of energy
something on those lines but he's like
if you allow me to die you will unleash
basically a foe that's far worse than
you can ever imagine
anybody's just like whatever man you
make assuming planets you got to go so
they let Galactus die and in his place
comes Abraxas and what you end up
finding out is Galactus was like they
gatekeeper and like on the other side of
this gate was a practices basically just
represents the destruction of all things
it's just destruction incarnate Abraxas
starts universe hopping from one reality
to the next wiping away and killing
every version of Galactus what Abraxas
comes back when you finally see what he
is and you're finally introduced to him
where he is is just littered with the
bodies of Galactus as Galacta like
Galactus is from all over the place and
life from all these different universes
dude it is insane it takes Franklin
Richards the son of Reed Richards this
reality-warping kid he resurrects
Galactus from the dead and then Galactus
takes the ultimate nullifier I think
Reed takes it or something like that and
they destroy Abraxas with it it's like
the coolest thing ever somebody text me
it's the coolest thing ever when it
comes to like the whole the whole
Fantastic Four thing and that's just the
Fantastic Four that's not even taking
into account like the x-men right like
we have our videos or basically kind of
like fleshing out what the x-men would
be like in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
and like not even going with that let's
say that it was just a bunch of one-off
movies and like they didn't fit in a
continuity anywhere or anything it was
just movies that were there that
featured the x-men coming out of Marvel
Studios but movie I would want to see
before any other movie would be god
loves man kills dude God loves man kills
is like the greatest x-men story of all
times took us up so Chris Claremont
riding the x-men for about 1975 so like
1992 eventually he leaves he wrote it
for like 17 years so he basically bails
out of the expert but during the time
when he was riding the x-men he
published an original graphic novel I'm
pretty sure it was written by Chris
Claremont and drawn by Bob McLeod but
I'm not gonna swear to that I'm probably
entirely wrong on that but the whole
idea is it introduced a group called the
purifiers and it's so cool
because basically mutants are just being
killed left and right like it's like the
set the saddest opening ever is like
these kids who are fleeing for their
lives and and when is it happening is
like they're basically taken out and
it's basically someone who's who's
basically says you know like your
mutants your you're a disgrace against
God you don't deserve to live and so
like right off the bat you're like okay
so these are like crazy fundamentalist
people then it introduces a guy named
William Stryker Foxx screw dis character
up so bad by making him a military guy
but he is ain't an evangelical he's a
religious fundamentalist who believes
it's his mission from God to kill
mutants that's what he believes and he
leads a group called the purifiers and
they're quote-unquote purifying the
world but they were so cooling they came
back you know
over the years but like William Stryker
is one of the most intriguing villains
to me because he's not been on like
conquering the world you know it's not
world domination or anything like that
he just believes that God wants them to
kill mutants and that's it but you've
also got things like the Friends of
humanity you got all these organizations
that oh my god dude bishop oh man
okay cool so here's a cool thing Bishop
you guys saw him in Days of Future past
he wasn't nearly as interesting in that
movie as he is and like Marvel Comics
but his origin stories cool so his
origin like his future comes from a lie
he comes from a future almost identical
to the Days of Future past the
difference is that in Marvel Comics they
launch an event called the House of M
and the House of M was a story where the
Scarlet Witch went crazy and basically
stripped 98% of the mutant population of
their powers and so following this with
Bishop having appeared all the way back
in like the earth the late 80s I think
we finally get an actual tried and true
origin story form but what you end up
finding out is that after the events of
house of M the first mutant born was a
girl named Hope Summers and she got her
name because cable basically rescued her
from the purifiers and all these groups
that were trying to take her out and
basically adopted her as his own took
her into the future and then named her
Hope Summers but the whole idea is that
eventually she goes crazy like she loses
her mind she becomes a villain and what
literally happens is over the span of
six seconds she wipes out a million
people and so because a million humans
are killed the government responds by
jump-starting The Sentinel program and
then basically Days of Future past
happens where the Sentinels start going
awry and they basically become
self-aware and they conquer the entirety
of the planet but the problem with this
is that eventually instead of like
humans and mutants being subjugated
under the entirety of the Sentinels the
humans and mutants come together and
what's called the Somers rebellion named
after Scott Summers the Summers
rebellion sees mutants and humans
casting off the Sentinels destroying
them in their entirety and then it
basically leads to the formation of like
the Xavier security enforcers and it's
basically just mutants who police other
mutants it's a really dystopian and
really dark future but this story is so
cool there's so many great things oh man
no mmm let me tell you some okay here's
what I want to see hmm here's what I
want to see I want to see the Illuminati
son that's what I want to see I want to
see the Illuminati okay a little bit of
history here Marvel wrote a story back
in the day called the kree-skrull war it
was
huge it was like this this
groundbreaking story in Marvel Comics in
a lot of ways because it was the first
like massive universe wide earth impact
II story they've done it was a massive
deal when it went on with the characters
because it was basically this idea that
there were these two races called a Kree
and the Skrulls another creed you're
probably familiar with if you've watched
agents of shield the scrolls I think
you're going to be the main villains of
the Carol Danvers movie the Captain
Marvel film that comes out and you know
next year in 2020 or whatever it is that
it gets released but the whole idea is
that these are two races who are just
impossibly old they've been waging war
against each other for millions of years
before Humanity was even a concept the
origin of the war is actually kind of
crazy the scrolls were initially just
like this benign explain you know
exploring race and the idea was that
they had showed up to the planet of
Halle which was occupied by two races
the Kree and the cotati
and the whole idea was it basically said
we want to expand our empire we're gonna
put both of you races through a trial
whoever proves to be the most valuable
and most in line with our ideals is the
one that will induct into our into our
empire and so they basically grabbed the
three and they put them somewhere I
think they put them both in the moon
actually and the whole idea is the Kree
basically used all the technology and
the resources given to them by the
Skrulls to build up like this massive
castle or something like that and the
Cotati built like a lush jungle and so
because of that the scrolls are just
like we like to go tidy better the Kree
freaked out and attacked the scroll
delegation they kill them all they
reverse engineer their ships and then it
just leads to a massive war that goes on
for like two million years or something
crazy like that but the whole idea of
that story of the kree-skrull war is
that it led to the - the idea to the
realization from like all the Earth's
really the leaders of the earth
superheroes that they all had a piece of
information that if they had shared
would have kept the war from coming as
close to Earth as a dent and so what
happens is like Charles Xavier of the
x-men
blackbolt of the Inhumans and like Tony
Stark Iron Man and Doctor Strange and I
think Captain America came on after
Professor Xavier left little member off
my head but then you also had like like
Reed Richards of the Fantastic Four they
all basically come together and they met
for the first time in Wakanda and they
tried to bring bring black panther into
a Ryan black panthers like you guys have
no idea how bad your screwing up right
now this will not end well do not do
this what they end up doing it anyway
and the whole idea of the Illuminati is
they basically share information they
never keep anything hidden and they
basically operate behind the scenes no
one's supposed to know that they're
there they just operate in complete and
total secret well it all comes back to
backfire on them when like after like
the first mission they have is basically
saying we're forming this group in
responds to the kree-skrull war so they
travel to the squirrel homeworld and
they're like hey man if you guys bring
your problems over to earth again like
we're just gonna come back and destroy
you and the scrolls are just like
whatever they kidnapped the Illuminati
they duplicate their genes after
studying and then send them back to
earth with them having no idea what
happened fast-forward like 20 years and
when the scrolls that duplicated the
Illuminati what they had done is start
going through and duplicating earth
superheroes led to this amazing story
called Secret Invasion where you didn't
know who was a scroll and who was a
human but there's so many things they
can do if they have the x-men and if
they had the Fantastic Four
there's so many things I'm sorry I'm so
excited people but it is an exciting
time right now because Disney may be
getting the X bit of the Fantastic Four
back it's not like the last video right
the last video it was like hey so like
rumor is they're getting it back now
it's like like people are coming out and
like yeah man like they're they've
they've pretty much got a deal done and
like it'll pretty much come out like
next week
most likely hopefully there's a really
good chance that he may happen we have
no absolute certainty if that's true or
not but I am do not ma'am so excited
right now breathe childlike I am so
excited I am so hyped right now but let
me know what you guys think down in the
comments section and and if they get the
rights back to the characters let me
know what story you guys would want to
see like your favorite story in all of
comic books whether it's a cross over
whether something like Secret Invasion
or like a tried and true Civil War VIN
or like do all do the original Secret
Wars the Beyonder ah - there's so many
things I could do let me know what you
guys want to see down in the comments
section and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]